gigi hadid gets emotional about her
sister joining her on the runway while
the weekend and Bella shares some major
chemistry and Lady Gaga receives angel
wings all at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show in Paris
[Music]
we're ready are you the iconic
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show aired on
CBS Monday night and Gaga graced the
stage along with the beautiful models
I feel welcomed into the angel family as
a unique and more rebel type of angel
the 30 year old singer gave two epic
performances and received her very own
white freight angel wings gigi hadid
second year on the runway was extremely
meaningful she got her first set of
wings and this year sister bella shared
the same sentiment posting this pic
ahead of the show to instagram sweetly
writing in the caption I cried when I
saw my sister put her wings on for the
first time something else that got us
feeling emotional Bella and her
ex-boyfriend the weekend's crazy
chemistry while she strutted her stuff
down the catwalk as he performed
[Music]
et's Kevin Frazier was with fella before
the big show where she praised her
former flame he's the best we're still
great friends
[Music]